mitch hedberg was one of the greatest
comedians of all time he might not be a
household name like George Carlin or
louis c.k but he'll always be remembered
for his signature style and
one-of-a-kind delivery i bought a
two-bedroom house but it's up to me how
many bedrooms are are though isn't it
unfortunately before he could truly
break through and claim the fame he
deserved Hedberg died of a drug overdose
in 2005 although his time here was sadly
cut short let's take a look at the life
of the amazing Mitch Hedberg Minnesota
nice when you think of mitch hedberg
slade back west coast's donor vibe you
might be surprised to learn that he
actually came from the Midwest st. Paul
Minnesota to be exact
despite the fact that middle America is
generally a pretty conservative region
Hedberg never really tried to hide his
liberal drug use I used to do drugs I
still do but I used to it was early in
his life in Minnesota that he and his
family discovered that he had a heart
defect
his mother claimed his condition often
caused him anxiety although the
coroner's report ruled that Hedberg died
of a drug overdose it's possible that
his heart condition may have contributed
to his untimely death the acting buck
Hedberg got his first big break on The
Late Show with David Letterman this led
to an appearance at the 1998 Just for
Laughs festival where he really made an
impression
Fox jumped on the Hedberg bandwagon and
signed him to a $500,000 development
deal to try to come up with a TV show
unfortunately Fox and Hedberg never
found a project that worked so he was
dropped from his deal but the next year
he went on to write and star in his own
movie
los enchiladas a film about workers at a
Mexican restaurant in Minnesota Jay
Chandrasekar of Super Troopers edited
the film and set on a podcast that
Hedberg was great but kind of hard to
work with because he and his co-star
would get too high to remember their
lines if I take further they were kind
of looking at each other by take six the
two of them were just literally standing
there looking at each other the film
premiered at Sundance in 1999 but that
was about the end of it lo Sencha Ladas
was never released to DVD and it's only
been shown a handful of times since its
premiere when his movie failed to gain
any interest
head bergs acting career kind of fell
apart as well after being cast as a
stoner in that 70 show he made a brief
appearance in the film almost famous and
later took a small role in the Lords of
Dogtown before his death in 2005 Comedy
Central blow out Mitch Hedberg first
Comedy Central Presents special was a
big deal but he struggled to win over
the audience his material was just too
different from what they were used to at
the time I don't have a girlfriend
I just know a girl who would get really
mad if she heard me say that the edited
version of the special makes it look
like Hedberg nailed the set but the
unedited version is totally different at
one point he just sits down on the stage
looking defeated but keeps going in the
end he won the crowd over but it was
hard work helping hand even though his
Comedy Central special was disappointing
Hedberg still had plenty of success on
the road
Time magazine even went so far as to
call him the next Seinfeld but even in
the midst of his growing fame he never
forgot the underdogs when Mike Birbiglia
was still early in his career Hedberg
went out of his way to help the new
comedian out Hedberg performed at
Birbiglia CD release party but he didn't
just perform he flew himself there and
refused to be paid and when Hannibal
Buress was just starting out Hedberg did
him a huge favor - when Hedberg played a
weekend of sold-out shows in Chicago he
let Buress and a few other inexperienced
comedians go on stage during his set as
Buress put it that's unheard of
comedians just don't do that
but Hedberg was apparently happy to give
any stand-up a chance that one act of
kindness kick-started Burres his career
as a stand-up comedian never say no
toward the end of his life Hedberg was
constantly touring he do three shows a
night then go to the next place and do
another weekend of shows his wife said
Hedberg never passed on a job
he'd been rejected so many times he felt
like he had to accept while he had the
chance or else all the rejections could
start coming back even at the peak of
his fame he never seemed to feel like
he'd been accepted so he relentlessly
traveled and performed until his last
days he had severe stage fright
it's strange to hear that a guy who made
his living performing in front of people
was also terrified of doing so but Mitch
Hedberg was just that
he told time journalist Joel Stein
during a 1998 interview I don't like to
connect with a crowd I find that if you
look at people's faces you see a
disappointed face and so the
prototypical Hedberg performance
involved dark sunglasses long hair
draped over his eyes and set long
staring contests with the floor he also
as the New York Times put it sometimes
closed his eyes as he performed remember
the guy pretty much always wore
sunglasses and he would still close his
eyes to keep the crowd away he would
criticize his own jokes on stage every
comedian messes up a joke on occasion
they're human too after all but for the
most part
comedians tend to ignore their flubs
moving right on to the next joke like
nothing happened
not Hedberg though he tended to ruminate
on his failed jokes criticizing them
onstage on a level that few comedians
could ever get away with dogs are
forever in the push-up position a joke
is dumb I'm aware that Deadspin likened
it to him breaking the fourth wall
turning from comic to critic if a joke
didn't land in an odd way it made him
more endearing and relatable to his fans
it didn't hurt that far more of his
jokes landed and crashed
he thought he could moderate his drug
use rather than kick his longtime drug
habit Hedberg attempted to moderate it
in May 2003 the comedian was arrested
for heroin possession which is often a
wake-up call for people to stop what
they're doing or at least try to Hedberg
had other ideas
in a 2004 interview with Las Vegas
weekly Hedberg claimed he was going to
do much less
so people couldn't associate him with
drugs anymore as he said you can't do
copious amounts of drugs and stay alive
so not all drug use has tapered off but
I've learned to just stay under the
radar
he thought the plan might help his
career theorizing during that interview
that since he got arrested for drugs
once any mistake he makes in the future
will get blamed on drugs so to make
himself look better he was planning to
do less drugs and be really quiet about
the ones he did do sadly the plan was
doomed from the start
arrests and hospitalization head Berg's
drug problem was never a secret though
most people didn't realize how serious
it was although he was open about
smoking weed or doing acid he kept his
heroin addiction out of his act then in
2002 he was arrested for heroin
possession and soon after he wound up in
the hospital his leg was so infected
from injecting heroin that the doctors
almost amputated it it was 13 hours of
surgery they took gum muscle out of the
out of his back and transferred it to
his leg once he recovered Hedberg
returned to stand up and sadly continued
his drug use in 2005 he died of a drug
overdose this morning we've learned a
popular comic from st. Paul has passed
away Mitch Hedberg died in a hotel room
in New Jersey on Wednesday though he had
a tragic end Hedberg was one of the most
interesting comedians of his time and
will be remembered for his exceptional
delivery timing and creative one-liners
he might not have been the new Seinfeld
but he never needed to be he was Mitch
Hedberg say your home thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]